we tend to begin our lives with a deeply
unrepresentative experience that of
being surrounded by people who care to
an extraordinary extent about us we look
up from the dreams and confusions of
early infancy and may find a smiling
face or two observing us with the utmost
tenderness and concern they watch us as
a rivulet of saliva leaks slowly from
the corner of our mouth and rushed to
wipe it away as if dabbing at a precious
canvas then indulgently stroked the fine
soft hairs on our delicate scalps they
declare us close to supernatural when at
last we succeed in pulling our first
smile
the applause rings for days when we take
our initial steps giggle totter fall and
bravely try to resume our progress it
isn't just at home at school the best
teachers encouraged us when we find
something difficult they understand we
might be shy they're keen to detect and
encourage the early tentative signs of
our particular talents then of course we
grow up and we're inducted into a
horrific reality we exist in a world of
astonishing indifference to almost
everything we are think say or do we
might be in late adolescence when the
point really hits home we might be in a
bedsit at university or wandering the
streets of the city at night on our own
when it occurs to us with full force
how negligible a thing we are in the
widest scheme no one in the crowds we
pass knows anything about us our welfare
is of no concern to them they jostle
against us on the pavements and treat us
as a mere impediment to their progress
with tiny against the towers and
brightly lit flashing advertising
hoardings we might die and no one would
even notice it maybe a stern truth but
we make it all the more so by focusing
only on its darkest dimensions we remain
grief-stricken
by how invisible we are yet we cease to
put this bracing thought to its proper
philosophical purpose that of rescuing
us from another problem which is Naurang
at us all the while an ongoing and
highly corrosive sense of
self-consciousness in another side of
our minds we haven't accepted the
indifference of others at all in fact we
know and suffer intensely from just how
much as we feel sure others are thinking
of us we are extremely worried about how
high-pitched and odd our voice sounded
when we asked the waiter for a bit more
milk we're certain that the sales
attendant noticed how out of shape our
stomach is the people in the restaurant
where we're eating alone are undoubtedly
spending considerable time wondering why
we have no friends at work they're still
dwelling on that slightly stupid thing
we said last month about the u.s. sales
strategy a person we went to bed with
four years ago is to this day thinking
ill of us in some powerful but undefined
way we don't really have any evidence
for this and yet it can feel like an
emotional certainty it can feel
intuitively clear that our foolishness
and less-than-impressive sides are being
noted and dwelt on all the time by
everyone at line every way in which we
depart from what the world considers to
be normal upstanding and dignified has
been registered by the widest
constituency to liberate us from this
kind of punitive story we may need to
conduct a deliberately artificial
thought exercise we may have to set
ourselves the challenge of examining how
long we spend on the foolishness or just
existence of other people how we think
and feel about other people we don't
particularly know is perhaps the best
guide to the workings of the average
human imagination to pretty much the
rest of the world we are the very same
sort of strangers or casual
acquaintances as we know and deal with
in our own daily experience and now here
the results can be surprising imagine
that we are in an elevator standing next
to someone
on our way to the 20th floor they think
they know that we disapprove of their
choice of jacket they think they know
that we should have picked another one
and that they look silly and pinched in
this one but in reality we haven't
noticed the jacket in fact we haven't
noticed they were born or that one day
they're gonna die
we're just worrying about how our
partner responded when we mentioned our
mothers told to them last night imagine
it's well on the way into the last bit
of a two-hour meeting that we sense that
a colleague's hair really is a bit
different today though we can't quite
put a finger on how even though they
spent a small fortune on their cut and
thought intensely about the wisdom of
visiting a new salon in other words when
we take our own minds as a guide we get
a far more accurate and far less
oppressive vision of what's likely to be
going on in the heads of other people
when they encounter us which is in the
nicest way not very much this kind of
news is both very bad and strangely good
on the one hand no one may notice when
we die on the other that also sure not
to have noticed when we spill some
orange juice down our front or do our
hair the wrong way it's not that we or
they are horrible a lack of caring isn't
absolute if we really saw a stranger in
trouble in the water we would dive in
when a friend is in tears
we are sympathetic it's just that for
the most part we need to filter our
everyday lack of care occurs for a
perfectly sane and forgivable reason we
need to spend most of our waking
energies on navigating and doing justice
to our own intimate concerns once we've
had to think about our relationship our
career our finances our health our close
relatives our offspring our upcoming
holidays our friends and the state of
our household there's just going to be
very little time left to reflect on the
suddenly high-pitched voice of a
customer or the outfit of a colleague we
are owed the upside of an otherwise
tragic insight we shouldn't just suffer
from the indifference of other people
we should where it matters properly
reciprocate it we shouldn't merely
suffer from being ignored we should
accept the liberation implicit
the fact that we are being so and then
in turn we should embark more
courageously on those situations and
adventures where a touch of foolishness
is always going to be a possibility like
the start of a new business a romantic
invitation or ask you a question at a
conference we may fail but we can
believe with new certainty that almost
no one will give a damn if we do an idea
that may above anything else help to
contribute to our future success
something which as we now know no one's
going to much notice or care about
anyway
at the school of life we believe that
confidence is a skill we can all learn
click now to learn more
you